[Music]  yes soon back again Bruno Mars is back  to perform on the finale of The Voice  [Music]  we're trying to party with you Bruno eat  Egon exclusively announced the 31 year  old singer will perform his smash single  24 carat magic on the singing  competition shows finale airing Tuesday  December 13th on NBC  [Music]  the entertainer is on a major hot streak  not only did he kill it on the runway at  the Victoria's Secret Fashion Show  he's also headed to Sin City ET  exclusively revealed in October Bruno  will take the stage on New Year's Eve at  the brand-new Park theater at the Monte  Carlo Resort and Casino  he's also slated to return for more  Vegas concerts in March 2017  [Music]